The next line, line 6.
The main class starts, which is called BlankCount.
And [COUGH] after that there's two constants that are being defined.
And one is the blank the other one is a sentinel.
And then we move to the main, which is actually the main the main body of
the class and also the main method for the program.
Everything is included into a try catch block, and
the first instruction is actually to initialize the InputStreamReader, ISR,
with a new InputStreamReader and takes the system in stream as a parameter.
>> So I believe on that line, there's also a problem because that
violates code the interface rather than implementation, so
they actually have the implementation class on the left, left-hand side.
It should be declared as the ab-,.
. as the abstract interface and
then the concrete implementation on the right-hand side with the new.
>> So, now, other people agree?
>> Yeah, I agree.
Yeah.
Bob’s right.
>> Okay then there’s the code declares two integers next and
count, and next is going to be use the as the next character in sentence, and
count is going to be used to count the number of blank counters,
which is the main goal of the, of this class.
>> I'm glad you stopped telling us that there's semicolons at
the end of each line.
It's that helps.
>> Well I think it's important, correct?
>> So before the semicolons though,
shouldn't we initialize these values like we have the ISR variable or both?
>> [CROSSTALK] Yeah we should initialize. >> All right, go.
>> Should we decide whether to character or an int?
The comment says character.
>> That's true. >> [CROSSTALK] Operation says int.
>> Yeah, that, that's excellent to pick that up.
>> Yeah. >> That's that comment problem again.
If you'd done slash star, maybe you would had written it right the first time.
>> Should, should we go for comments on the right side of the?
Or should we put them above?
If they get their own line, maybe it'd help us read it better.
I don't know. I, this is, this is going back to, to line four up above.
I, I don't, I'm not quite sure when we,
when we want them beside the code, when we want them above the code?
>> Well, there is nothing in the standard that we use
in the company, but that's fine.
I mean, if you want to pick a,
you know, a way to do it >> We could make a standard.
>> [CROSSTALK] That's fine. We can make a standard.
>> We can make a standard right now.
>> I'd like a standard, yeah, mm-hm.
>> So what's, what's the standard?
We going to go slash, slash all the way or slash star?
Slash star seems a little more robust.
We can, you know?
You don't have to use as many slash slashes.
Javadocs uses slash star kind of, that kind of structure when you do.
>> I thought it was kind of old fashioned but that's okay.
We can use slash star. >> What's wrong with old fashioned?
[LAUGH]. >> [LAUGH].
>> Okay, Dr. Bud continue please.